uh you can see live pictures there uh in
paris uh we believe this is the french
government speaking about uh what
happened at the champions league final
outside the stad france on saturday
night let's just have a listen in now
hopefully we've got a translation
we
had on the auspicious ministry of sport
a meeting with all the partners
that were involved with the final uh
match on friday night of course some
ministry for sport and the home office
the police
and the prefer
the ref presented from uefa and the
french football federation the
representatives from the state of france
and also
the perfect who was responsible for
major
events
so we had a long meeting where we
had exactly the same interpretation with
regard to what actually happened we're
going to explain it to you
so first of all with the minister i
would like to uh express our regrets
with regard to the organization of this
final
because uh some people were not able to
see the whole of the match and of course
i deplore also
the errors that took place before this
football match first of all i'd like to
remind you that this match was organized
at the start of france
and the decision was made three months
ago
after the geopolitical situation in
moscow
and uh
normally it takes a very long time to
organize a match of this size so three
months for the start of france and for
the french football federation
we're asked to do this carried out this
match so uh we talked about four
different subject matters first of all
uh we regret that there was this
organization with regard to welcoming
the british supporters
as opposed to the spanish uh supporters
and thirty thousand to forty thousand
english uh supporters a figure confirmed
by uefa the stad of house the french
football federation and the police
they found themselves at the stadium
with
tickets or with fake tickets and we saw
that in public transport to the
organization of more than 40 percent
or more that took her public transport
to come to the stadium
seventy thousand uh took urban transport
and uh
normally you know how many people go to
the stadium and six thousand by uh coach
and
other forms of transport so the uh
presence of these thirty thousand forty
thousand british supporters
sadly is already known uh
in madrid during the uh final match in
where there were already some issues in
madrid
and then to that was added that there
was in fact a strike of the rerb
so many of the spanish supporters had to
take the rerd and they had to go out to
from a narrower
exit and so therefore that gave extra
difficulties and we'll come back to that
at 2100 when
the match was supposed to start
97
of the spanish supporters were present
the spanish and the english had 20 000
bases each at 2100 only 50 percent of
the british supporters had got into
their section
which does show the difficulty that
arose and only arose
from the entrance
relating to the liverpool supporters and
not the other entrances the spanish
supporters and the rest of the
spectators
what was noted there was massive fraud
at an industrial level and organization
of fake tickets because the
pre-filtering
by the stadium and the french football
federation saw that 70 of tickets were
fake tickets uh coming into the star de
france
once going through the pre-filtering
stage it was also noted that 15
of fake tickets
also where
after the
first filtering in other words more than
2 600 tickets were confirmed by ufos
non-validated
tickets even though they've gone through
the first filtering the massive presence
of these fake tickets uh
of course was the issue that meant that
there were delays uh three times three
times the beginning of the match was
delayed and now i'd like to hand over to
minister
and i'd like to very
thank the
forces of law and order but also those
who worked in the state because they
were very calm and they were able to
avoid drama
and so thank you for
organizing the pre-filtering but lifting
it when there was too much pressure to
avoid a drama and that was a decision
that was made by the prefecture
to obviously avoid any kind of deaths or
people who were seriously injured and i
see lots of things in the media and on
social networks
with regard to arrests
there were 29 arrests that took place
within the stadium and more than half of
those arrests
were british supporters because they'd
intruded
inside the state of france now i've had
them to the minister
thank you very much thank you minister
thank you for this a very detailed
debriefing of these two intents for two
hours and i'd like to thank all the
stakeholders
for being transparent and after all it
was a very serious event
but everyone wants to ensure that this
will never happen again but at the same
time
because of course there is a pain we
mustn't forget that this match was able
to be played nevertheless uh under
conditions that were satisfactory which
meant that there was a winner
and
there were not any seriously injured
people no victims and they dispersed
calmly and there was no violence between
supporters
and uh
in relation to your very detailed
presentation the only thing i'd like to
add is that
this uh
statement by uefa
of 2
500 tickets that weren't
real tickets
some people had bought a ticket and were
deprived of a match
and of course we'd like to say how sorry
we are to all those people
because their saturday night experience
was completely spoiled
2700
people and we asked uefa who said
that they those people should be
identified and they could be compensated
soon
and to try to overcome their frustration
i believe that
what i would also like to add
is the next stages what's going to
happen
well the next stages that we've set up
together the minister and myself we can
uh define them as a three plus one so
the pivotal major central point is to
try to really understand precisely what
happened during this massive fraud as
far as the ticketing is concerned the
home office minister said
and uh there are witnesses of this so
those figures will correlate this over
30 to 40 000 people without tickets all
with fake tickets and we saw some fake
tickets and we can see
they're professional because those
tickets look incredibly like normal
tickets and of course
that's meant that some controls of
course you didn't notice it but on that
particular point we really want to be
able to above and beyond
the inquiry from the prosecutor babini
and also the police we want there to be
a very detailed in-depth uh
inquiry
with uefa to see what's happened why
this happened and how and to what extent
uefa certainly heard our request and now
we're waiting
for this rapid setting off of this
inquiry
and the second
the second aspect
is that i asked my services
which is an inter-ministerial department
for sports events i asked him to gather
together in a transparent way and as
exhaustively as possible
all the analyses that were mentioned
this morning so that within 10 days we
are able to
know precisely what happened so we can
shed light on all the aspects that we
knew from our side with regard to what
happened i've just said it before of
course there'll be some aspects that
will have to be elucidated by other
players but we ourselves we will try to
look at all the information that we have
in order to be able to ensure that we
can have as much transparency as
possible with regard to these
regrettable events from saturday night
and the third aspect is that
with the home office
inquiry we want to try to
reinforce
the monitoring of these major events
we've seen we have to improve
we've got to improve in risky matches
certain aspects with regard to managing
the flows especially with regard to the
zones first filtering second
filtering and we've got to make sure
that we look at electronics for
ticketing as closely as possible so that
we can actually avoid
fraud as far as the ticketing is
concerned and that's something that's
absolutely
essential
and we'll also
make sure there'll be a reinforcement of
public order these risky uh matches are
so the plus one doesn't relate to the
events of saturday night but those of
last night
and once again there we are absolutely
really upset to see in which uh
supporters behaved
badly so with jihad
we want to
work together sports justice home office
and we want to look at this fight
against
the supporters behaving badly in the
area of football and we want to make
sure that we are firm but at the same
time to have faith in the strength of
dialogue
and also with the national division
in the fight against hulu
but also working with the associations
of supporters we want to reactivate this
dialogue we want to reactivate these
this reflection to make sure that the
foot that we love so much
that gives rise to passions doesn't give
rise to
bad behavior thank you very much for
your attention